foreign
facts are your friends
[Music]
been in his bell bottom rock music
like an epiphone Flying V plugged into a
fuzz box
Reds way to go he's looking at me like
do what
you know how I roll that's exactly
um all right so
I need to make this abundantly clear on
the front end of this facts of your
friends
I this is not a conversation about
judgment this is not a conversation
about me
um casting blame or Stones I know
there's a lot to be said about what
we're going to talk about for the next
few minutes so
um I've learned this the hard way on
social media I can say something like
hey moms or dads don't yell at your kids
and some of you hear that and you go
um you're right I need to not do that
but some of you immediately get
triggered and you go oh yeah well Dad's
and husbands like whoever I'm not
talking to they need to stop you're
right so this is one of those topics
that the moment I say it you're gonna
either go not me or you don't even know
what I'm dealing with or I'm such a
loser or some of you are really really
underwater with this issue and so I want
to be as gentle as possible and be
honest be honest and
This Is Us just sitting down having a
chit chat over a card table okay so just
think of it um there's not me talking at
talking down to you is me talking with
you okay I want to talk about drinking
alcohol
um here's here is
um
why this became an issue with me
um I
rarely drink I just don't like it that
much I'll have one drink here there
um
it's really really rare that I have two
not because I have any judgment against
it whatever in fact there's times I wish
I did I just I just don't feel good I
just don't like it I don't feel good
um I just get bloaty and uh
um
but then I got this woop strap and I
noticed even when I would have one glass
of wine if it had one beer or one like
one of these fancy Bourbons one of my
colleagues has
my sleep would flush itself down the
toilet it was it was so disregulated I
couldn't believe it and then I started
asking my other friends here at the
office who also had whoops and we were
comparing data and talking about it
because it was a relatively new product
at the time this is a couple years ago
and it has happened to everybody
and what was interesting is all of us
were quietly on our own worlds
essentially just quitting drinking for
one reason it screwed up our sleep so
bad that we could go to bed at the exact
same time and wake up at the exact same
time but our sleep was so screwed up
um and so then my wife got it and she
noticed it right
and then in short order it was one of
those huh oh yeah
our dinner bills when we go out to eat
the bill was so much less
and then grocery bills were so much less
and then it thinking about hey do we
need to Uber here or do we all that
stuff just kind of shifted and so I saw
what happened in my personal life
things just got
um less expensive less burdensome and my
sleep was better
and so I began wondering like why why
was I having one or two drinks like what
what was that getting me and that
started me down a rabbit hole of the
literature
um and I was gonna go through all the
literature and stuff listen
um Andy huberman Andrew huberman over um
at The huberman Lab podcast you I'm
recommending you go find it
um after you know the show go find it he
does a two hour plus two and a half hour
master class on alcohol
all the research what it does in your
brain which hormones and brain chemicals
it affects
he really does his best to find some
redeeming quality I'll be a little more
there's just very little redeeming
quality it just messes up most of your
body ethanol is a poison I wish it was
another thing but it's a poison
and so then Kelly sent me this article
the other day that was published by the
AP News
post-pandemic the rate of deaths that
can directly be attributed to alcohol
Rose nearly 30 percent in the U.S during
the first year of covid
um
the rates have continued to be up net
over what they've ever been
um
the rate of such death has been
increasing in two decades before the
pandemic by seven percent or less each
year
in 2020 they Rose 26 percent
it's the highest rate recorded at least
40 years
such deaths are two and a half times
more common in men than in women but
both Rose in 2020 the study found and
there's been a couple of great articles
and even a remarkable book I'll link to
it in the show notes the um the titles
just left me here
um
about alcohol consumption in women
and how the cool thing for women became
oh yeah she drinks beer or she drinks
whiskey or drinks Bourbon and that was a
way that everybody felt women were
getting a seat at the table
but there is a particular pressure among
women to oh yeah I can drink this or
this and it was a it was a part of a
overall power play part of a move
and women are paying a toll with their
physical and psychological health
and then there's the whole uh wine
Wednesday or wine in Wednesday or what's
it called what's it called Kelly
there's wine Wednesday There's so so
much around it's a stay-at-home mom
culture
day drinking yeah yeah you can buy cute
little shirts you know yeah Rose all day
and all that stuff and you notice like
you should go to Target or go to any of
these little Boutique shops or Walmart
it's all like sweatshirts and little
towels and little things just about how
fun day drinking is or because I have to
do it it's my only way to get through my
life and then I I noticed it when Mad
Men came out but it just all across the
country office complexes man everybody
started drinking more they start
drinking more and I don't know if it's
because it looked cool I don't know if
that's the show I just I just noticed a
non-scientific correlation between the
two there's not nothing causal about it
everybody's just drinking more
a lot
um
and then there's these uh Jama the
Journal of American Medical Association
they looked at a wider range of deaths
linked to drinking so there's death
during by people who just drank
themselves to death right
but then there's motor vehicle accidents
suicides
um often suest people who are
um considering Dying by Suicide will
drink enough to take their inhibition
away
and it leaves them with no breaks on a
forever decision Falls cancers
pancreatic cancer liver cancer and other
things
so there's
thousands and thousands of tens and tens
and tens of thousands of deaths are from
drinking too much over a long period of
time and tens and tens and tens and tens
of thousands of deaths are tied to acute
intoxication I fell down I got in a
wreck I died by Suicide whatever it
happens to be
and then there's obviously
chronic dangers such as high blood
pressure and stroke and heart disease
and liver cancer all this kind of stuff
so here's all I want oh to say today in
today's facts of your friends it's a new
year
as I've had this conversation with more
and more people across the country it's
particularly with moms and with business
owners and um and then more and more
with police officers military folks dads
uh it's running the gamut okay
I want you to be very intentional about
examining or re-examining the role
alcohol plays in your life
here's where that's really important
I uh used to pass out a survey to all my
incoming students particularly like I
did at the law school I did it at a
couple other places but it was just a
social norming survey
what's your drug use what your alcohol
use uh what's your sexual habits I
wanted it to get a snapshot of what the
student incoming student body thought
about the world how they responded to
the world and I would always read these
statistics to the students and what was
always fascinating is
the students thought 95 percent of
people got drunk once a week
but the self-reported data was actually
65 percent of people got drunk once a
week so they were off by a chunk right
so I would read those and and the point
was hey if you think everybody's getting
drunk all the time the reality is
they're not if you think everybody's
having a glass of wine at 11 30 in the
morning just because the baby won't stop
screaming or because your boss is
kicking your butt they're not actually
not and it's this weird self-fulfilling
prophecy
I always remember the statistic that
that broke my heart and would silence
the room and it was 80 to 90 sometimes
mid to high 90s ninety percent of people
drank to felt feel more sexy drank to
facilitate engagement and sexual
behaviors
and every time I told the entire
Auditorium the entire theater
if you have to
drink
in order to be with somebody
that is a way you are overriding your
body's innate systems
to do something your body is telling you
it doesn't want to do
and the same can be said for going out
for feeling sexy for having hard
conversations for having fun for going
to sleep
if you are drinking to
override your body's signaling system
that sleep is scary that there's too
much chaos going on in your life that
your partner isn't safe that your work
environment is a mess that you are
uncomfortable being around people those
are individual things that you can work
on with a counselor that you can work on
with a community of friends that you can
work on with a journal some of those
things
but when you drink to cover up parts of
your life just so you can endure it
man
I just want you to hear me say your
life's worth more than that
and I would rather have a season of
discomfort getting to the bottom of why
does my body
tense up when I'm around you because
we're married let's get to the bottom of
that let's just don't have three or four
drinks just so we can have sex once a
week
let's don't do that
now if it's a part of if it's a I'm not
going to tell you to not drink okay I'm
not going to tell you to not enjoy your
life to not go have fun all that kind of
stuff
um
I just want you to be conscious about
how and when you're where you're using
alcohol
also
if you are struggling with an alcohol
addiction
let this be the Year let this be the
podcast let this be the minute that you
Push pause on this show and you call
somebody and you say I need help
day one
or that you get out your phone and find
the next meeting and you're there
sitting in the back row
looking around wide-eyed but you're
there
let this be the year that we're done
poisoning our bodies and our
relationships in our mind and we say
we're going to engage life and it's
going to be hell on Earth especially at
the beginning
but you are worth that
you're worth that
so again
it's not about judgment this is about
y'all are just my friends
it's not about you won't see me with a
drink someday you probably will
um it's about being very conscious of
what is this drink doing for me and more
importantly what do I need this and if I
don't need it why am I doing it why am I
doing it
the alcohol death is growing in the U.S
and it's up to us to change that
some of that's going to be most of
that's going to be us deciding let's
build a life worth living
let's build a life
let's build a non-anxious life that we
don't have to run and hide from
let's get people in our lives let's
create a context where we can walk right
through the middle of it
so that's back to your friends
examine your relationship with alcohol
you're worth